so I was just reading a really moving
and inspirational story and I think with
all the bad news out there it's great to
have a little bit of hope and to focus
on the good things everyone said well
sigh I just wanted to start right off
the bat by telling you about this here's
the headline this is really great it
says gravitational waves could collide
sucking earth into a black hole so there
is hope I mean there's a there's a
potential solution to our problems and
and I don't I just want to let you know
so you could you could go about that
your day today with a little bit of a
smile on your face
unfortunately the chances are slim of
the earth getting sucked into a black
hole
but we can keep our fingers crossed
right now in the meantime I want to talk
about body positivity it's a little bit
of a weird segue I get that but it's
it's hard to segue into anything once
you've started with the earth being
annihilated by a black hole so you just
got to dive into it and go for it a body
a body acceptance model named Tess
Holliday is on the cover of Cosmo
magazine Tess is morbidly obese and
we're told that this is a historic
moment a great moment for the world for
mankind because it promotes body
acceptance and body positivity and so on
and fat acceptance you know is I think
the phrase people use now now
I don't I don't want to spend any time
dissecting the particulars of this
magazine cover because it doesn't matter
Cosmo is a trash magazine as it is so
it's just it doesn't really matter there
a garbage magazine doesn't matter what
they put on on the cover of their
magazine you can't it's not even legal
to buy a Cosmo magazine if your IQ is
over 45 I don't know if you knew that
but it's you're only allowed to buy it
if your IQ is under 45 if you haven't IQ
over that of say a cucumber you're not
allowed to buy a Cosmo magazine because
of the the the terrible effect that
would have on your mental health
but you know if your IQ is under 45 then
you really don't have much of a mind so
it doesn't doesn't really meant so so in
that sense it makes no difference
and as for Tess Holliday herself I wish
her nothing but good things I have
nothing against her personally I don't
know anything about her all I know is
that she's a morbidly obese model whose
whole mission in life apparently is
self-acceptance and self love and self
esteem and every other word with self in
front of it what I would like to talk
about though what I would like to do is
talk about just the whole idea of body
positivity this obsession this this this
thing we do now in society where we
insist that everyone love their body
just as it is we insist that everyone
find themselves attractive and beautiful
we insist that everyone accept and love
everything about themselves we insist
that all body types are wonderful no
matter what and on and on and on or not
I want to talk about that because I
think it's I think it's harmful and
counterproductive
but before we get into that I should
stipulate that I agree um that there has
been for a long time unrealistic beauty
standards imposed primarily on women
it's something that women women mostly
deal with men have their own version of
it a little bit of it but it's it
certainly has a greater effect on women
the pressure to be beautiful is not
something that I myself have really
experienced and thank God for that
because obviously I missed the beauty
train and it ain't coming back to pick
me up so it's good that it doesn't it
doesn't matter for me and so I'm a man
and I'm also married so I really don't
care it doesn't matter to me I be people
in the comments will make I'll see
sometimes they'll make they'll make very
insulting remarks about my physical
appearance and you know what any time I
read those the only thing I say just
smile and I think well it's good thing
I'm married then so I don't care I mean
it really just really doesn't make a
difference I just feel bad for my wife
honestly but you know joke's on her I
guess
so there has been in in recent times and
I you know if I was a woman maybe a
little bit be a little bit more
difficult for me to have that attitude
because there's just a general there's
greater societal pressure for women to
you know be attractive and I get that
and it's good to the extent that we have
reacted against that that's good because
it's ridiculous that women should feel
pressured to be a size negative seven
and to have no blemishes and no
imperfections and all that it's good
that we've gotten away from this idea
that a woman must be anorexic to be
beautiful and I don't say that as any
kind of you know joke or anything about
anorexia by the way I mean I just mean
it literally this this was the message
that we were giving to girls and that's
where a lot of the eating disorders in
anorexia where it came from because we
were basically telling them implicitly
that you know you've got to have an
eating disorder to be attractive that
obviously is is deranged and crazy and
harmful getting away from that is
wonderful however we seemed have gone
way to the other end of the spectrum
like way to the extreme other end of the
spectrum going from anorexic models to
morbidly obese models going from only
this type of body is good to any body
type any weight is good and I think
that's the wrong approach I think the
whole body positivity thing is wrong and
I have two reasons for that
number one
not everything about your body is
necessarily positive not all of it
should be accepted or loved or embraced
okay morbid obesity for instance is an
objectively negative thing because it's
unhealthy it will kill you
and it will cause all kinds of other
health problems as well your your body
is not meant to carry around hundreds of
pounds of extra fat that's not we
weren't meant for that it's it's it's
just not good for your body it has it
has you know
it has a terrible effect on pretty much
every aspect of your body because none
of it was made to support that right
from your internal organs to your bones
just everything so there's no that's not
something we should embrace because it's
unhealthy
and it's also something that very often
develops through an unhealthy and
inactive lifestyle so when you're
embracing the morbid obesity you're also
embracing the lifestyle which caused it
and I get it okay I talk every anytime
we talk about this issue of obesity
being overweight so on you're always
gonna have the people who say well yeah
but what about you know it's possible
for someone to become morbidly obese you
know even if they're trying to eat
healthy I mean somewhat someone wrote to
me yesterday I mentioned this issue
briefly yesterday on Facebook someone
wrote to me they're very angry and they
said they said well you know there are
people who are obese now because they're
going through cancer treatments obesity
is one of the symptoms of a brain tumors
which I don't know if that's true or not
I will assume it's true I didn't look it
up you know okay and that's obviously an
exception but we have to ask ourselves
when we look at the overall problem of
obesity in America do we imagine that
most of that is because of brain tumors
that most of it is because of disease
really
and if so why is there so much more
morbid obesity in America than there is
in Ethiopia
obviously it's clearly it has it's
primarily not solely but primarily
driven by lifestyle and by diet
so we've got a lot of fast food here we
eat a lot of processed food we also on
average spend five hours a day sitting
on the couch watching TV so that is that
has a lot to do with the obesity problem
it's not disconnected from it right
clearly I'm acknowledging that there are
exceptions but the overall problem is
primarily driven by poor dieting poor
lifestyle choices and that's all and and
not something that we should accept now
I'm talking here about morbid obesity
when you talk about obesity or being
overweight yeah the issue with that is
that those terms that becomes have
brought in so much and become kind of
ambiguous like if you look at a chart of
what is considered obese for your heart
for your height according to the medical
community you'll see that it's like
everyone you know I was looking at one
of these charts but right before I
started rolling here I was looking at
one of the charts just out of curiosity
and it said that I'm I think it said
that I'm obese or no no it said I'm
overweight let me I have it right here
Medical News today has a chart and it
gives you the height and then it gives
you what the what the weight range is
for normal overweight obese and
extremely obese so I'm six foot tall and
it says that norm the normal weight
range is 140 to 177 140 pounds for a
six-foot man I hadn't been hundred forty
pounds since like eighth grade 140
pounds for a six-foot man that's
emaciated you're just you're just skin
and bones how was that normal that to me
seems drastically underweight and then
overweight from my weight range you know
full disclosure here I'm being
I'm being a transparent so overweight is
184 to 230 they're saying that you're
overweight as a 6-foot man when you
reach 185 pounds I'm like 195 200 so I'm
overweight I'm like I'm pushing the
scales towards obesity folks I am
according to this now I don't know maybe
I am obese you know I run 2 miles a day
it's possible to Moebius at the same
time I I do think that overweight and
obese have become categories that are
you know have maybe been widened too
much no pun intended I apologize but
when you get into extreme obesity when
we talk about someone who is you know 5
foot 7 and weighs 275 pounds well then
it's obvious that it's a problem it's
unhealthy it is catastrophic ly
unhealthy effect now
if you are morbidly obese
or on the other end let's say you're
someone who is dangerously underweight
if you're massively overweight massively
underweight you should try to accept it
you should try to fool yourself into
believing that it's a positive thing you
shouldn't hate yourself either you
shouldn't despair over it
people shouldn't make fun of you for it
or mock you obviously but you should
take it as a as a challenge to overcome
a change to make that's all what's wrong
with that
we really need to get past this idea
that we as individuals should celebrate
and love everything about ourselves
simply because it is ourselves the
problem is that that philosophy leaves
no room for improvement it leaves no
room for honest self-assessment it will
prevent you from becoming a better
healthier person because any positive
personal change has to always begin by
looking at yourself and saying this
aspect of myself isn't ideal I want to
change it
we all have those negative facets of
ourselves the only difference is that
only certain negative personal features
have their own lobbying groups and are
the subject of marketing campaigns
telling us to accept and celebrate it
for instance one of my many personal
flaws is that I have a bad temper okay
so I'm telling you a lot about me I'm
obese I have a bad temper for instance
you know so but but as someone with a
bad temper I know it shocks you to learn
that about
I know that I need to change that that's
a flaw that I have I need to work on and
nobody in society would tell me
otherwise though that's the difference
there isn't any bad temper acceptance
movement they're not going to put me on
the cover of a magazine screaming with
it with it with a headline that says bad
tempers are beautiful okay that's not
gonna happen
because everyone recognizes that bad
temper is not beautiful it's a it's a
character flaw you got to change it but
overeating gluttony sedentary lifestyles
and the morbid obesity that often comes
from it with that there are people
telling us to accept it and love it and
that's why it's necessary to speak up
and offer a corrective to that flawed
and dangerous idea number two
back to something I said when we talked
about the idea of self-love it applies
even more in this case
rather than being constantly obsessed
with body positivity and with developing
a positive image of your own body maybe
the better course is to is to stop
looking in the mirror for five seconds
and live your life live it outwardly
stop obsessing over how you look one way
or another because it's vanity either
way to obsess over your perceived flaws
or your perceived beauty is vanity
both are vanity and it's a shallow dull
miserable way to go through life all
this stuff about we're supposed to love
our bodies oh I love my body I'm so in
love with my own body I mean I guess we
consider that healthy for people to go
around talking about I love my body so
much but if you've gone bet you know if
you got like 100 years ago 200 years ago
and you walk around telling someone I
love my body do you love your body
they'll look at you like a crazy person
they'll say what love your body what is
that
it's kind of a weird it's a weird thing
to say hey I'm so at hey guys I love
this so much I am so in love with all
this I got to tell you how much I love
not just to walk around looking at
yourself oh my gosh I'm in love I'm in
love with me no that's not that's not
how we should go through life
and we say that everybody should think
that they themselves are beautiful
well everyone isn't beautiful first of
all there's a certain objective quality
to physical beauty if there isn't any I
know people say no there's no objective
quality to beauty well then it doesn't
mean anything it doesn't mean anything
to say if everyone's beautiful then
beauty has no meaning to take pride in
beauty or to feel good about it it's
like you might as well feel good about
the fact that you breathe you might as
well say I'm a breather I tell you right
now your major look in the mirror and
say I am a breather because it's the
same thing as looking in the mirror and
just telling yourself you're beautiful
I'm beautiful everyone is beautiful
we're all beautiful wealth and no one is
beautiful then beauty means nothing you
know you know all we've done in that
case is we've removed we have removed
beauty from the people who actually have
it and from the things that actually
have it by trying to give it to
everybody
there is an objective quality to beauty
to beauty I mean think about art for
instance there are certain great classic
pieces about the Sistine Chapel okay is
a beautiful work of art
now we'd like to say beauty is in the
eye of the beholder but not now there is
there are subjective qualities to it how
exactly it moves you you know what
emotions what thoughts it brings to mind
that's all subjective but if you walk
into the Sistine Chapel and look up at
the ceiling and say yeah I'm just not
into that I mean I think that's good or
if you walk in and you say Oh disgusting
that is gross well then there's
something wrong with you you are wrong
you are wrong for reacting though it if
you look out at a at a serene peaceful
mountain lake and it's a it's a there's
not a cloud in the sky
you know it's 65 degrees and which is
the objectively best temperature by the
way and there's a little birds flying by
and everything there's trees all around
if you look at that and you say yeah you
know doesn't do anything for me don't
like it no it's ugly
gross
uh yeah I'd rather go look at this
dumpster over here yeah that's me you
know yeah yeah and then you go and you
sit and you you sit in front of a
dumpster and stare at it and say wow
you're wrong okay so beauty is not
totally in the eye if that's if that's
your reaction you're meant you're
something mentally wrong with you and
spiritually wrong with you same holds
true for physical beauty of four people
there are some people who are just
physically beautiful
and that's all they have they have it
it's a quality that they have
and if it's something that has if
there's an objective quality to it it
means that some people can be physically
beautiful and some people aren't
so you might not be beautiful I'm not
that's okay that's fine
statistically
you probably are not beautiful
statistically
because most people are
now which that's fine that's it's fine
not everyone has to be
what about it's the same things like
it's like as I said you know
statistically not everybody can run a
mile in 5 minutes and 30 seconds it's
kind of a it's a rate it is rare to find
someone who it's comparatively rare to
find someone who can do that someone who
has that kind of speed and endurance
right and that's that's fine it's fine
if you can't run a mile in 5 minutes and
30 seconds
now what about beauty on the inside it's
true that Beauty the beauty of kindness
the beauty of virtue and generosity
these are far more important but not
everyone has that beauty either some
people are ugly inside some people are
beautiful outside ugly inside some
people are ugly outside ugly inside
that's possible too there's this dumb
cliche we do these where we kind of
think that we assume that every ugly
person must be beautiful inside not
necessarily what was that stupid movie
that came out years ago Shallow Hal with
Jack Black
and all of a sudden he was able to see
you know Tony Robbins gave him magical
powers so that he could see the the
inner beauty of someone and in the movie
it's every every physically ugly person
he met was actually beautiful inside
well it's an I mean it's nice to think
that's the way it goes but it but it's
not necessarily the way it goes
some people have it all there are people
who are beautiful outside beautiful
inside but the last thing we should do
is encourage people to spend time
convincing themselves that they are
beautiful outside and inside people who
are beautiful on the inside and that is
people who have beautiful who are kind
generous and virtuous and all of that
compassionate
right
those people they would never go around
saying it and they don't spend time
thinking of it
because there's for anyone who really
has virtue there's an element of
humility in all of their virtues in
order for it to really be virtue
so the moment someone says I am
beautiful on the inside well then you
know that they probably aren't unless
it's a child saying that but if it's an
adult who goes around saying something
like that they're probably not beautiful
on the inside because lacking humility
is ugly preoccupation with yourself is
ugly
talking about your own positive features
is ugly
someone who's really beautiful on the
inside they just they don't think about
it they don't focus on it
because they're humble as well it's one
of the things that makes them beautiful
point being we should try to forget as
much as possible about ourselves we
should look at ourselves and within
ourselves only as long as it takes to
discover our flaws so that we can
correct them and then we should live our
lives from there looking out into the
world at our loved ones at nature up to
God not in the mirror all the time not
not into our own emotions obsessing over
our feelings about ourselves what a
miserable way and this is how people
live their lives now where they're not
only obsessed with their feelings but
they're obsessed with how they feel
about themselves when they sit around
all day how do I feel about myself right
now what a terrible way to live awful
and you know I think I'm not saying that
we should have no positive feelings
about ourselves at all
but I think rather than walking around
with this sense of our own alleged
beauty
I think we should it's better rather to
have a sense of our dignity maybe that's
maybe that's what some people mean when
they say everyone is beautiful or we
should all you know we should all think
that we were beautiful
maybe it
want to give me a benefit the devil
maybe what they really are struggling
trying to say is dignity
everyone has human dignity and we should
all be aware of our dignity because that
is definitely true and human dignity is
a phrase that seems to have been lost so
maybe you forget about your beauty
forget about how you look remember your
dignity
because if you focus on dignity instead
of beauty then I think you'll be spurred
on to act with decency and self-respect
and humility and virtue and all of that
because a person can feel that they are
physically beautiful and then go on to
be a stripper or a prostitute so their
way of expressing their beauty is to
defile it that happens all the time in
this culture and people are encouraged
to act that way people are encouraged to
express their physical beauty by by
desecrating and it's a terrible thing
but if they have a sense of their
dignity
rather than their beauty then they would
never be a stripper or a prostitute
and their their beauty would be
accentuated and highlighted and
protected if they really have a sense of
their own of their own dignity
so maybe that maybe we should get away
from that
body positivity everyone's beautiful
blah blah blah self-esteem self-love
just self dignity the dignity of
yourself maybe that's what we should
focus on and that's what we should
instill into our kids
that you are a human being your creature
may made by God you have dignity for
that reason it is a it is a an immutable
dignity that no one can take away from
you
and you can choose to live
according to it and live in a way that
defends and protects and cherishes that
dignity or not
and that's the choice that we have to
make
all right
so remember your dignity
and we'll leave it at that have a great
weekend everybody
and if we do get sucked into a black
hole sometime this weekend then
[Music]
I guess all well you know I'll see you
on the other side Godspeed